[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Amel Bourne karenz diner c'est le nom de
ce restaurant australien au concept
simple cuisine délicieuse mes services
exécrable les serveurs ont pour mission
d'être les plus mal poli possible avec
les clients et ça marche les clients en
redemande le concept est clairement
affiché pour éviter les mauvaises
surprises sur le site internet et à
l'entrée du restaurant il y a un panneau
qui annonce asseyez-vous et fermez-la
personne n'était parnié pas même les
enfants avec leur joli dessin
et encore moins les véganes
une dizaine de restaurants de ce type
doivent t'ouvrir cette année en
Australie aux États-Unis mais pas en
France où l'on a déjà de l'avance avec
les serveurs Paris avec toutes les
polémiques qui apparaissent tous les
jours on s'est dit et si on abandonné
nos bonnes manières et qu'on laissait
exploser notre rage l'espace d'un
instant tous les employés sont ravis de
vous aider en cela
nous voulons vraiment que vous deviez la
carène que vous voulez
devenir
une femme blanche insupportable se
plaignant toujours pour rien merci
[Applaudissements]
il était mignon
ça nous fait flipper mais quand même
pour nous rassurer ou pas en fait bon
j'avais envie de d'avoir le le le
sentiment
les aspects sont plutôt bon le carré
Saturne d'Uranus est en train de se
détendre
[Rires]
elle n'a pas échappé au covid au
Royaume-Uni la reine d'Angleterre
Élisabeth II a été testé positive au
covid la souveraine de 95 ans ne
présente que des symptômes légers Boris
Johnson le Premier ministre a lui a
souhaité un bon rétablissement
[Musique]
j'adore la fête j'adore mes copines
j'adore me prendre en photo je m'aime
beaucoup
j'ai confiance en moi je trouve que
c'est la base qu'il faut s'aimer qu'il
faut s'adorer parce que personne ne le
fera pour toi personne ne t'aimera
autant que toi tu t'aime oui je pense
que je plais ouais
je pense que je suis beau gosse quoi
c'est la
vérités de même toi pas du tout en fait
s'affronter à Juju et là le mec il a pas
froid aux yeux il veut prendre la place
de chef et franchement moi je viens je
le connais par cœur là je vois qu'il
sourit mais souris gris je vois qu'il
est pas content vous vous dites qu'avec
un physique pareil ce n'est pas le genre
d'homme à chercher une relation sérieuse
et bien vous avez à moitié raison car
Julien est effectivement un séducteur
[Musique]
j'ai enchaîné pas mal de conquête
j'étais un donjon dans ma région
[Musique]
plutôt élevé niveau prétention arrogant
si vous avez aimé mon portrait n'hésitez
pas écrivez-moi venez découvrir mon
petit concombre
mon petit cocon dans ma belle Normandie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais dans un bar les gens en général
commencent à boire et il commence à me
reconnaître
la fin de soirée arrive et là je vois un
gars au loin comme ça je dis bon bah tu
vas pas y couper tu vas prendre ton
petit selfie
[Musique]
il regarde comme ça là et puis là il y
avait le brassard police et puis il me
dit contrôle d'identité avec 16 billes
[Musique]
ah bah oui on le voit tous les soirs à
la télévision
et là le flic me dit ben je vais vous
faire une confidence il y a quelqu'un à
l'extérieur du bas qui nous a dit
qu'avec Xavier Dupont de Ligonnès
et le flic je dis bah vous avez pas
l'air content
ils savent que j'ai la promener et là je
viens de m'enlever la bête je le sens
bouger dans moi et j'ai peur j'ai peur
qu'elle rentre dans moi la bête c'est
bon j'en ai marre
j'ai déjà pris quand tu perces la
saucisse qui a bien mijoté un coup de
jus qui te brûle
vraiment de la saucisse mais bien
évidemment
toi je n'ai aucun doute
très facilement
c'est pas gênant en tant que tu es
spectateur parce que la passion amène
parfois aux excès non
on s'envoie
des critiques parfois sévère si c'est
Monsieur Marty qui aime plus les données
que les recevoir mais
2 minutes après vous riez ensemble
ça s'appelle quoi ça s'appelle la vie la
vie
Eric verte attention c'est profond pas
forcément rose et bleu pour les Français
d'abord parce que la vie c'est quelque
chose de merveilleux la vie et c'est
quelque chose de bien c'est mieux
c'est mieux que la mort